it's one of the most obscure forgotten
and unknown countries
in the world want to test this allow me
to ask you three questions one have you
ever heard of uzbekistan
two would you know where to find it on a
map and three could you name its capital
if you answered all three questions
correctly congratulations you're an
expert in international geography
if not don't worry it's not unusual and
today you'll have the chance to discover
many more curious facts because dear
viewers today on visualpolitik
we're talking about uzbekistan
[Music]
it may not be very popular with tourists
but with more than 30 million
inhabitants uzbekistan is the most
populous country in central asia it's
also
incredibly young that's young in both
centers of the word not
only because one out of every three
inhabitants is under the age of 14 but
also because the country was part of the
former soviet union so modern uzbekistan
is only 28 years old
and dear viewer it's a remote country
it's so isolated from the rest of the
world that on top of having no access to
the sea like liechtenstein it's the only
country on the entire planet that is
surrounded by countries that don't have
access to the sea
either and its neighbours they're pretty
obscure
too kyrgyzstan tajikistan turkmenistan
kazakhstan and afghanistan
well i suppose the last one there is
very well known but not for good reasons
anyway as you can see if you want to
have an adventure in the 21st century
typical of an explorer get away from the
known world and feel like
david livingston or even marco polo then
you could go to uzbekistan but folks
obviously this isn't a travel ad so
here's a question why on earth do you
think we're talking about uzbekistan on
visualpolitik
any ideas well what if i told you that
this country is
at an interesting crossroads
you see uzbekistan is a country roughly
the size of california but it's only got
1.5 of california's gdp
it's a country where only one in every
three inhabitants lives in a city and it
has to make
a very important decision it needs to
decide whether to commit itself to a
full reform program
that will set it on a path to becoming a
21st century economy once and for all or
alternatively retreat back into
obscurity from the rest of the world
and what can i say here on this channel
but we love this sort of thing in this
video we're going to see what's
happening in uzbekistan but first we
need to introduce you to a leading
character
so have you heard of islam karimov well
listen up
[Applause]
[Music]
heavy hand full pockets
sometimes everything changes and yet
things remain practically the same and
that's
exactly what happened in uzbekistan in
1991 when the country declared its
independence from the crumbling soviet
union
at that time the man on the screen now
islam karimov was the general
secretary of the communist party in
uzbekistan as well as the president
of the uzbek soviet socialist republic
and of course if he had all the power
why should he let any of it go and
that's the question karimov must have
asked himself and not surprisingly well
he decided not to
[Music]
on september 1991 when it wasn't yet
clear if the soviet union would end up
disintegrating
karimov saw his opportunity and declared
the independence of uzbekistan on
december 29th of that same year
elections were held they were so
fraudulent that they would make even
nicholas maduro look like a democrat
karamov got 88 percent of the votes and
from then on you know what
while the results they kept on improving
azeroth managed to maintain a
suspiciously high percentage of the
votes in subsequent elections
he only needed to make a call to the
electoral board and
dictate the results of the elections all
before they were even held of course
once that was done the deal it was
sealed
[Music]
the upshot folks is that during his 25
long years in power islam karamov became
the master of uzbekistan he was
one of the most ruthless tyrants on the
planet a guy who had no qualm saying
something publicly like this
i'm prepared to rip off the heads of 200
people
to sacrifice their lives in order to
preserve peace and
calm in the republic karemov oversaw
truly terrible humans rights abuses for
over 25 years
as the uzbek president hugh williamson
human rights watch
during his years in power uzbek media
censorship was one of the strictest in
the world
arrests and convictions of journalists
and social and political activists were
an everyday event and the police and
secret service used torture
as part of their normal protocol
of course as a result nobody in
uzbekistan dared to speak out of the
president
in addition karimov regularly used
expropriation as a mechanism to
consolidate his power yes sorry hugo
chavez you weren't an innovator in that
field you were kind of more like an
apprentice he also maintained a lot of
the economic policies that he had
learned during the soviet era policies
such as currency controls completely
artificial official exchange rates a
huge amount of state interference in the
economy
and more and more stuff like that
furthermore he increased the country's
isolation by having terrible
relationships with most of uzbekistan's
neighbors
all this explains why under his rule the
majority of the population
was poor seriously poor even though
uzbekistan is rich in hydrocarbons and
mineral resources for example it has the
third largest gold reserves
in the world by the way we can't give
you poverty statistics because the uzbek
government officially determined
law that there is no poverty in the
country and if it doesn't exist well
then of course it can't be measured
to give you an idea though consider that
the average salary is 225 dollars per
month for jobs that are paid according
to the official regulations and of
course for under the table jobs
it's even lower
[Music]
and as you can imagine caramel's family
and in a circle they've accumulated
an immense fortune carol's own daughters
have visited the most glamorous places
in the world
have shared experiences with hollywood
a-listers have released albums jewelry
lines perfumes they've just done
whatever they want really but folks
perhaps the best way to see how
immensely tyrannical
despotic and autocratic karimov's
government was is by taking a look
at what was happening in the cotton
sector this is traditionally the most
important economic activity in the
[Music]
country
is because uzbekistan is actually one of
the largest cotton producers in the
world
so can you imagine a country where every
year the leader enslaves a very
significant percentage of the population
to work for him and no don't be fooled
this time we aren't talking about taxes
we're talking about
forced labor
[Music]
well that's exactly what's happening
with uzbekistan
[Music]
each year between september and november
to collect the cotton harvest the
government mobilizes between
one and two million people in virtual
slavery conditions
to avoid going you had to send someone
else in your place or face the
consequences
most were public servants such as
doctors and teachers or workers from
companies that were contracted by the
government
yep you heard that right in fact a lot
of hospitals were left practically
without doctors because the government
had sent them to pick
cotton you come to work with all the
makeup
wearing nice clothes good shoes and the
poly clinic director runs and says i
need 40 people in the field
the bus is outside hurry hurry dr kiddo
yatova to the new york times
cotton is mandatory for everyone the
government gave orders to pick and you
will not go against these orders if i
refuse they will fire me we would lose
the bread we eat
an uzbek school teacher and that's not
the worst of it for many years a lot of
these workers
were children who had stopped going to
school in order to pick
cotton for the government
[Music]
the system it worked like this the
farmers received free labor and then
sold the cotton to the government at a
very low price
then the government sold it to tech our
companies or exported it to produce
clothes all over the world at a price
far greater than what they paid the
farmers in that way cotton became one of
the largest
sources of government revenue anyway as
you can see garemov he didn't fool
around
perhaps another example of how despotic
and authoritarian karamov was can be
found in how he treated his own daughter
see
karimova was so to speak his favorite
daughter there was even speculation that
she would be his heir
she lived life to the fullest surrounded
by luxuries and celebrities and was very
popular among jet setters among her many
activities she was even once ambassador
to spain
well it turned out that karamova caused
a huge problem for the uzbek government
because she had been dealing with
hundreds of millions of dollars for
international companies in exchange for
false concessions in uzbekistan
and then to top it off she argued with
and publicly confronted her mother and
brother and
well that was simply too much one fine
day karimov sent the secret police to
his daughter's house with a mission
typical of hollywood movies
[Music]
dressed in black they assaulted
caranova's house throwing themselves
from helicopters with ropes
caught her and they locked her in a room
in a mansion carrimova one of the
richest women in the world never saw her
father again and nobody has seen her in
public since
we know that she's been transferred to
an uzbek prison the trial that condemned
her was held in her own kitchen
as i said before karimov he does not
fool around
[Music]
surprised well despite all of this the
truth is that karimov was a good ally of
the west especially the united states
and probably there we need to hold up a
second because i mean how could western
countries
ally themselves with such a tyrant
[Music]
well let's just say there are two very
compelling reasons on the one hand
uzbekistan is a predominantly muslim
country despite this karimov's
government was strongly opposed to
radical islamists and has persecuted
them with the same heavy hand with which
it kept its people subjugated
well probably an even heavier hand
actually evidently karimov didn't take
this line due to personal conviction
religious tolerance or to defend
personal liberties but because radical
islamism
represented a direct threat to his power
on the other hand uzbekistan has a
border with afghanistan and that's
something that the united states after
afghanistan's invasion could really use
in fact the pentagon installed an
air base in the south of the country in
exchange for you guessed it a financial
donation to karamov's regime
in 2002 alone the uzbek government
received 500
million us dollars you know normal
international politics
but folks in 2016 with karimov's death
this all came to an abrupt end and now
the question is has a new era
really begun well listen up
[Music]
change or no change
check out this headline uzbekistan
emerges from isolation with one billion
dollar bond sale
[Music]
in february 2019 the government of
uzbekistan made its first bond issue
in the international market by issuing
euro bonds worth one
billion dollars in london and you know
what international investors practically
snatched them out of their hands the
demand was eight times greater than the
offer the question is
what investor in his or her right mind
would lend money to a government like
this
[Music]
well dear viewer the fact is that after
karimov's death is number two the prime
minister
shafkat mirzkelev rose the role of
president this came as no surprise as he
had been
karimov's prime minister
however to everyone's surprise ms kiev
announced a lot of reforms that would
open the country to the world
for example he improved relations with
his neighbors prohibited forced labor in
the cotton harvest purged the
high-ranking officials from the security
services that had
led the repression freed a lot of
political prisoners and removed 18 000
people from a government blacklist that
had prevented them from traveling or
being able to work just by improving
relations with their neighbors and
reopening border crossings trade between
uzbekistan and the rest of the central
asian countries has increased by 50
since 2017 as just two years
and that's not all most of the changes
by far have occurred in economic policy
the new government
has eliminated capital controls and most
price controls it has announced the
privatization of most public companies
it has decreased tariffs and given free
rein to uzbek companies to export
without having to ask the government for
permission or pay them a fee
they have also announced lower taxes for
uzbeks and particularly for companies
that
invest in the country this is basically
opposite of what macri has done there's
a president that should take lessons
from the president of uzbekistan
[Music]
and as the country's officials have
traditionally been very corrupt the
finance minister
mr kukharov has decreed a three-year
moratorium on all company inspections
while the government improves its
processes and decreases bureaucracy
interesting move
[Music]
the point is that these are all reasons
that the forecasts for the country's
future have improved
so much so that the government can now
issue debt in the london market
without investors fleeing now does this
mean that uzbekistan has been completely
transformed
well no not at all uzbekistan although
better now than with karimov still has a
repressive government
censorship still exists and free
elections are still not in sight and of
course the new president still has a
huge amount of control over everything
that happens in the country let's just
say that the process has kind of just
started but folks we're just gonna have
to wait and see how things play out with
time
and we're gonna be watching very closely
because you can't say that it's not an
interesting story in fact i think this
video was very much
visual politic so i really hope you
enjoyed this video please do hit that
like button if you did and don't forget
to subscribe for brand new
videos and hit that bell button also
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcast who
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also this channel is
possible because of patron
and our patrons on that platform please
do consider joining them and supporting
our mission
of providing independent political
coverage and as always
i'll see you next time
you